jetzt nicht rot sah willkommen war ein
video schneider vom flugzeug ist das
erste flugzeug voll große flugzeuge
richtig spektakulär ja etwas geht ich
hoffe euch jetzt ein gut ich habe mich
heute was ganz besonderes überlegt das
letzte jungs mädchen thema legt schon
wieder etwas in der vergangenheit
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht er lag
dort der früher im ganz früh schon auf
diese jungs mädchen china aufgegriffen
oder aufgefahren was ist jetzt richtiges
deutsch keine ahnung auf jeden fall
kamen ganz deutschland von mir diese
videos so beeindruckt man in jungen oder
was bin ich gar nicht machen ich meinen
job ist eine große community und wird
man also folgendes ich habe jetzt eine
schöne community deswegen interessiert
mich eigentlich viel mehr eure meinung
meine meinung könnt ihr euch noch
ansehen von vor zwei jahren hat sich
vielleicht ein bisschen geändert aber
ich hab euch auf netzwelt und
entwicklung gefragt mal kurz ein es ist
auf jeden fall wichtig dass sie mit der
folklore das dilemma bald wieder hinter
extremes also erstmal was findet ihr
mädchen an und jungs oder an jungen
generell attraktiv ich habe mir da zehn
punkte auf gesucht war echt zum teil
überrascht und wie gehen bereit mal
zusammen durch und nicht sagt ein
bisschen meine meinung zu
und ja wenn er bock drauf das gegenstück
also dinge die jungs ein mädchen
wirklich attraktiv finden braucht jetzt
meine jungs hier schreibt den kommentare
meine meinung will dazu gar nicht merken
es gibt nur euch kommentiert darauf ein
bisschen und ich bin gespannt
bei 15.000 gleichkommt das video metzger
[Musik]
super witzig datenträger comedy here are
a few wunsch war für mich ist wieder
anfangen macht wieder weiter ab so
leuten ganz kurz durch ganz oben in der
eu noch ein video von mir verlinkten
nicht ganz viele von euch gesehen haben
dafür nicht ganz so gut angezeigt wegen
sex up lohnt sich auf jeden fall und
mehr wollte ich gar nicht sagen hier
viel spaß
erster punkt ich fange jetzt erst mit
den sachen die ich wirklich bestimmt 200
mal geschickt bekommen ohne spaß und
zwar schreibt die bild
reiten ein bisschen frei traurig dass
ich darüber nicht immer auf die augen
denn ich finde schöne augen ist wichtig
von selina haltelinie 1er generell ab
und zu dem ich eigentlich gar nicht viel
sagen muss ich meinen augen schön ich
hätte auch lieber blaue augen eigentlich
obwohl ein schon nicht gewinnt wirklich
sehr schön so die marius rap ich finde
es total attraktiv an jung wenn sie eine
schöne art visuelle haben wie gut
gestylt ist und nicht zu geschlecht mir
und ich finde es geil wenn jungs lange
wimpern haben glaube ich mich echt
gefreut weil in der schule haben immer
alle mädchen gesagt ich hätte es gern so
lange wimpern wie du weil mein wimper
ich finde das eigentlich gar nicht so
cool war früher war mir das immer total
peinlich dass ich so lange will man ab
wie mädchen das er gerne haben wollen
aber meine wimpern sind echt lange ich
weiß nicht ob wir das sehen oder sieht
man dass ich will weitermachen
[Musik]
ich weiß gar nicht ob die immer noch so
lange vielleicht auch kürzer geworden
aber wir machen weiter
minute schreibt ich finde dich minute
hätte jeder hat zu diesen blick und wenn
du dazu noch aussteht wo ammann könnte
schmelzen wenn er dich so anschaut
kann man das kann mich auf jeden fall
verstehen beide nicht und da habe ich
mich gefragt und war mir dann jungen ist
eben winter ein junger bin zwar ein
junger aber stehen mädchen nicht so
darauf wenn man immer eine kleine beule
in der hohe werk welches mädchen
getroffen und erste entwurf iran und
erzielt sein
ich kann den kleinen tipp geben das ist
glaube ich freue mich dass auch gar
nicht zu weit aus dem fenster lehnen
aber ich glaube das ist nicht so das
kommt eher schlecht über sehr schlecht
sogar ganz ganz schlecht okay nicht da
kann ich auch voll und ganz verstehen
niqab schreibt wenn jungs nicht nach den
ganzen klischees gehen wie zum beispiel
mädchen sollen die ganze zeit puffert
was ich dazu sagen kann sowas ist
natürlich so was geht wenn man das ernst
meint geht das wirklich gar nicht aber
das ding ist es gibt sehr viele jungs
die mine ist wirklich nicht ernst sagen
es aber trotzdem einfach weil ich will
jetzt nicht sagen witzig jetzt für den
jungen aber schon so ich mein ich würde
niemals meiner freundin sagen es jetzt
mal hier oder so das könnte weiteres
keine ahnung und warum machen wir
verhängen
und wenn ich das mal sagen dann meint es
nicht ernst auch wenn ich hier mal
wieder putzen sollten sie nicht weil
irgendwer die nächste sache das hört
sich jetzt wahrscheinlich total blöd
dann hat man auch zu dass er total blöd
an aber ich finde es total attraktiv
wenn jungs einen guten po haben dachte
ich immer als erstes beschreibst du mit
dem jungen julia haye war es schick wir
doch mal bisschen bild von einem darf
sich halt immer als erstes tor
aber okay wenn das so ist ihr könnt ja
meine kommentare schreiben als mädchen
okay da auf der viele von euch glauben
oder ob euch das egal
wobei natürlich kann ich verstehen ich
mein wenn dies jetzt komisch aussieht so
was machen weiter wenn die adern an den
händen heraus fahren wenn man das
schlüsselbein fand ich an sich etwas
verstörend so weil sich das komisch
anhört einfach das schlüsselbein sieht
sieht man bei manchen jungs nicht das
schlüsselbein das schlüsselbein oder
damit dass eine schlüsselbein ich meinen
die frau meines wissens nicht
das ist sehr wichtig juli lena hat mir
geschrieben ich finde es ultra sie sven
jungs rote wangen hab keine ahnung wie
man das nennt aber haben das letzte
freundin festgestellt dass ihr das
wirklich attraktiv im rote wann habe ich
jetzt wurde war okay am erste sein das
habe ich noch nie in meinem leben so
gerate aber mein gott warum ich kann ja
ein okay er noch einen punkt wenn sie so
tun als würden sie was können aber sich
dabei weh tut weh tun zb bei sportarten
ich könnte jetzt mal wieder sah ich kann
echt guten handstand habe ich ja schon
mal gezeigt und ich kann vielleicht
haben auch versuchen hier im handstand
zu machen okay leute passt mal auf ich
war für ein tour lechtermann gut machen
jetzt mein oberschenkel das als gut
präpariert jahre so vielleicht eine art
ich glaube seien jetzt zehn punkte
er kennt er meine kommentare faymann
wird seine jungs wie sie hier immer noch
voll auf dem fuss leicht gibt dann die
nächste folge schickt auf jeden fall
hier weit vorbei weil bing.com leider
nicht bestellt hat jana europa wird
immer gespendet an einen guten zweck und
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder um 14
uhr sv klar